the last point and you touched upon it
already a little bit was the purser
vation of Jews and Christians you still
have synagogues you mentioned that there
were over like 600 during the siege of
Sutterville over you know after what's
considered the greatest genocide here
after world war ii you still had a
before the Geneva Conventions you had
prophet mohammed peace invested be upon
him who laid the cone of conduct for
combat and one of those thing is not not
killing innocent men women and children
and preserving places of worship which
you said that muslims actually preserved
synagogues you talked about also that
that the muslims at that time they were
wearing the the burqa yeah that is a
story from some Second World War as you
mentioned you know Sarajevo it's also in
European history and tourist maps it's
well known as Jerusalem of Europe
because nowhere else except the original
Jerusalem you can find you can find
religious temples or old temples or for
confessions just in 300 meters you know
we can find synagogue mosque Catholics
and an orthodox church so those temples
and religions were living in coexisting
here for centuries when something like
that was completely strange for most of
the Europe for most of the year most of
the prejudice we still have today about
the Ottoman Empire not only in Bosnia
but also in Balkans Greece from Greece
Bulgaria Serbia also are coming from
19th century from the time when Ottoman
Empire came and the time of decadence
you know with lots of problems uprisings
you know Wars so but 14 and 15 century
really Balkans and in that time was near
and Herzegovina was oasis of tolerance
you know in the time when Europe was
fighting in religious wars especially
17th century and and the end of
sixteenth century after information and
after and all of these advocates of war
between you know Catholics and
Protestants you know
in Europe so yeah and also about your
question about the Jews after Jews were
expelled from Spain and Portugal after
in 1492 by Ferdinand Isabel you know
Spanish monarchs they were welcomed in
in Sarajevo beside other cities you know
and parts of Ottoman Empire though they
settled here and they started their own
businesses you know and to Holocaust
they were around ten percent between ten
and fifteen percent of population in
Sarajevo and during Holocaust Muslims
were saving jewish girl and women by
clothing them to bukas that is something
which really really lots of people in
Europe also probably here in Bosnia
don't know you know it's and lots of
these families and people were awarded
by Yad Vashem you know Julian this is a
historic this is a sound
yes yes you know this is something now
because it's a shame that a lot of this
is like forgotten hidden you know
history that's not really talked about
yes yes yes especially you know when
today that Buca or you know these you
know traditional way of clothing present
you know during centuries here in the
Middle East is considered as as a you
know oppression method or something that
it's nothing good in it so